the next Labour government will stand up
for Britain and ensure that our country
takes a strong and confident place on
the world stage the threats we now face
are not generally the old threat from
single states they cross borders and
boundaries and they are more complex
than their deeply dangerous but more
traditional interstate rivalry of the
past they can only possibly be tackled
by concerted action by countries working
together all around the world the
difficulty Britain faces in navigating
this new global order i believe is being
fed made far worse by decisions that our
own government has made was there ever a
more apt symbol of britain's isolation
and waning influence that when david
cameron was absent as the leaders of
Germany and France try to negotiate
peace with President Putin of course the
European Union needs to change on
immigration on benefits on the rights of
national parliaments EU leaders are
reluctant to support us in part because
they think we have one foot already out
of the door we are stronger as a leading
partner in the European Union and we are
weaker when we are not worried about
losing power that conservatives an
outrunner do everything they can to talk
up the prospects of the Scottish
National Party and ping Glashow McGann
Scottish nationalism this is incredibly
dangerous for our country see I believe
the real task for Britain is not to
divide between one nation or another but
to build the United Kingdom that works
for all a country that is working for
people at home is a country that can be
more confident abroad